The Amazon is burning.
A record number of fires over 72,000...
...have been detected in the world's largest rainforest this year.
Brazil's National Institute for Space Research reports that's an 83 percent increase from last year.
Environmental groups say the policies of Brazil's president Jair Bolsonaro...
...encouraged deforestation of the Amazon, which in turn allows for more fires.
Bolsonaro, in turn, alleges that environmental groups started the fires to embarrass his administration.
Meanwhile, the jungle is aflame.
Here, a motorist captures thick smoke pouring into the sky from one of the fires.
The Amazon covers over two million square miles.
It's home to indigenous groups as well as thousands of species of plants and animals.
Two-thirds of the world's plant species can be found there...
...and it's seen as a vital hedge against the carbon emissions that contribute to climate change,...
...a loss that becomes more pressing as global temperatures continue to rise.